asesinado por dictar clases el 16 de
octubre de 2020 el cuerpo de samuel para
ti fue encontrado decapitado cerca a la
escuela donde trabajaba con 47 años el
profesor de historia y geografía fue
salvajemente atacado por un refugiado
checheno de 18 años quien murió poco
después a mano de las autoridades no
constituyan
haití asesine uno de nuestros
conciudadanos fue asesinado hoy por su
trabajo por enseñar a los estudiantes la
libertad de expresión la libertad del
creer y no creer el invertido clave de
un pacto a padres y estudiantes estaban
en shock al otro día del atentado
si todavía tengo un poco de miedo por
esta situación tengo miedo de que vuelva
a suceder y no quiero que vuelva a pasar
con otros profesores porque es gracias a
ellos que aprendemos chico secular con
dichos samuel para ti quería que sus
alumnos reflexionarán sobre las
complejidades que conlleva la libertad
de expresión el 5 de octubre durante una
clase mostró caricaturas del profeta
mahoma a sus estudiantes les dio la
opción de no mirar e incluso de salir
del aula dos días después el padre de un
alumno lo acusó en redes sociales de
islamofobia y pidió su expulsión esto
atrajo la atención de un adolescente de
otra ciudad radicalizado meses antes
abdullah khan sort of trato de
identificar a su futura víctima y se
acercó a unos estudiantes ofreciéndoles
300 a 350 euros hasta la fecha los
jueces han procesado a 15 personas
incluidos menores de edad y manuel
macrón otorgó al maestro el título
póstumo de caballero de la legión de
honor